[Music]
turn this off anyway no no not that way
you know it keep going keep going
[Music]
love's lift us up where we belong
where our frisbee it's fine
from the margins
[Music]
louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's June which marks louder with
Crowder's third annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you
across the globe learning and
appreciating all the great cultures this
planet has to offer this week allow us
to transport you to the oft persecuted
what ass-kicking culture of Israel
[Music]
they do that so Israel
thanks to Dolan broadened by the way at
dole broaden for the idea of Israel
culture appropriation my really
interested third year in a row it caught
on and we're going to be looking at I
think seeing the best live costume every
week this this month before ultra to see
see who wins a cultural probation
contest costume contest mighty dapper
over there my friend you're looking like
I look more like Mary Poppins had sex
with Dustin Hoffman and hook siddik was
the goal on the show he's gonna be
thrilled with the get-ups no I'm not as
angry as Sally Kohn last year with
Sweden about razor sores on the show and
let me talk about Samantha bee we're
gonna be talking about the Forbes top
100 apparently no athletes there were
women but I think behind cultural
appropriation months people who don't
realize is to appropriate is to
appreciate one that's and so we always
want to Israel I don't know here's some
little facts from Israel our brilliant
researcher the beast reg as we call him
Israel is actually home to the city with
the most chess grandmasters in the world
mmm I would have thought they'd be Asian
if Israel thank for actually it looks
the Mighty Morphin Power Rangers had no
idea a little pissed off now that came
to us from Israel but again they put in
nothing but Asians in those suits I love
how it's like Jason Billy the black guy
and then once again suits it's all just
14 year old female Japanese gymnast yeah
and a little-known fact also is really
only functioning democracy in the Middle
East
oh that's awkward
we'd take care of it but we know we'd be
in the nightly news so please always do
is not a foam on Twitter not gay Jared
made us cry terrific how much I thought
your photo shops again your costumes and
your suggestions yeah uh what would you
like and also who would like to see for
long-form interviews by the way we have
some coming up we have some changed my
mind's coming up next week some hidden
camera segments a long-form with Dennis
Prager obviously Jordan Pederson but who
else we're always looking for people you
want to hear an interview with an hour
for FM family obligation historian
conclusions we good I apologize for
ready player one yeah wasn't that bad it
was not that bad also Jurassic Park to
I'm surprised you took that one on I
know at G Morgan Jr IDF resident in
chief thank you right I feel so powerful
in this yeah from our Jewish bladder
feel that way that's better
a Jewish wine I think it's a Jewish name
right thanks for doing your research it
actually I looked it up spend computers
are you ready to do research and
overlays you already get it right I'm
ready over here you can follow me on
Twitter don't sweat it I'm gonna form
you at Elon Musk enstein you think he's
wearing black because of the outfit or
easy this was very difficult for you the
tough one to be here and I don't think
it's black I don't think he's mourning
what his what his people that I think
he's mourning this episode good good
okay so news of the day listen now
president Donald Trump has now this is
trending invokes the War of 1812 not
really the war but the fact that you
know English colonists colony and Canada
burn in the White House had a call with
Justin Trudeau this comes to us from CNN
Trudeau press Trump on how he could
justify the tariffs as a national
security issue and in response Trump
quipped to Trudeau
didn't you guys burn down the White
House referring to the war issue of 1812
and let it go yet of course listen
there's been a long-standing tension
between Trudeau and president Trump's
it's not a secret and we actually have
exclusive footage of the phone call I
believe that is needlessly insulting of
course we do what about much we are okay
this is how it's gonna go okay you're
going to stop the tariff and you're
going to start up all the your end of
the deal won't be pushed around by the
likes of you oh the guys you burned out
the White House excuse me Oh White House
you put it down at 1812 was a bold move
okay caught us by surprise but that's
just because don't expect their friends
to burnt out their British colonies okay
you're sticking Jumpman did I remind you
about the Revolutionary War the Mexican
American War the spanish-american war
the Civil War freed those guys okay
Persian Gulf War World War one to seek
if you don't buy the appears acute
there's gonna be a three quote oh that's
right I forgot because you guys bet over
for the British I looked at people who
fought about to become the greatest
country the world has ever seen frankly
the greatest your people bent over and
took it at the okay frankly that's why
you still have that old hag on your
buddy
we have Washington Lake and great men
frankly the best man they're gonna make
a Koi to be okay it could have been coy
with Trump with my face at the side of
it you know it should be on the other
side of the coin no be still be back in
Europe it's almost like he takes it the
most is is he so transparent with his
schedule like you know he doesn't he's
not aware of it but you know exactly he
was probably Wikipedia himself that
morning stumbled a product cut across
the page Oh 1812 and like I'm gonna work
this hey hey do you believe this not in
my house do you think it's Fox and
Friends obsession you just know you can
know exactly where he's getting points
this is like breaking news for him you
know it's good the National Institutes
of Health are spending three hundred
fifty thousand dollars on a new study or
I guess they spent three the final
lesbians are using the right form of
contraception leading researchers Jenny
Higgins an associate professor in gender
women's studies as a surprise the
studies examining quote unique barriers
lesbians and bisexuals key word being
bisexuals have to adequate contraceptive
care just so you know the massive study
began with a questionnaire beginning
with are you a lesbian and ending with
them collecting a check that's it and it
may sound absurd some say this study was
simply meant to parlay funding actually
into their next study regarding the
vexing correlation between gay men and
fondness for breasts looks like that's
correlate correlation does not equal
causation yes
and another side another what another
quarter million to uh to deliberate over
the new FAA rules for Penguins so that
was enough but who also happened to be
gay I should have clarify these are
getting into the spirit right Stephen
can't get their backs the more it sits
lesbianism is not linear it's it's it's
a sphere two circle it's a circle of the
spectrum so the more lesbian you become
actually the more susceptible to
pregnancy it's impossible million
discovery I love what they tossing
bisexuals like we're gonna study
contraceptive care I don't think and
bisexuals cut the check I cannot this is
this is a true story right this is a
true story yeah indeed I'm like I'm like
certain passenger history I take that
back
no no he's only think about for this
violation of the German constitution
literally is we did over that time we
were doing a veteran remember that not
dated and it was a great guy kind of
hilarious I can't say that I would never
be able to go back it's an actual
violation of the German constitution
this part will have to be scrapped from
there yeah exist part will not be
scrubbed from the episode so everybody
better keep rolling those burns
speaking of angry raging lesbians at
least they seem so Cecil Richards CeCe
you'll reach Richard he'll feel not the
lion the bad one Planned Parenthood
Planned Parenthood same she sparked
outrage I hate to use it when she but
she tweeted the Trump administration
policy of taking children from their
families is immoral we as a nation are
better than this hash tag families
belong together so I want to make sure
you understand this yeah Cecile Richards
president of an organization that
profits off of literally dismembering
babies and sucking them down a tube is
expressing moral outrage over deporting
illegal immigrants yeah I just let that
sit in yeah most of the time when Adolf
Hitler told Winston Churchill that he
was being a total dick or Mao accused
the Chinese citizens of senseless
violence and scratching my tanks you're
going to wear well
I just bought those white Wow hey you
what can't use cha clear this is this is
she later explained yourself that after
seeing all those born alive children and
tweeted her expressive tweet all that
money down the drain that's really what
she was upset speaking of expressing
herself and also likely a raging angry
lesbian who knows I know she's married
but I would love to meet that husband
Samantha B apologized and just as you
would think it's the worst apology it's
the worst non-apology it's it's not even
a non-apology
it's just bad you know a lot of people
were offended in angry that I used an
epithet to describe the president's
daughter and adviser last week it is a
word I have used on the show many times
hoping to reclaim it I never intended it
to hurt anyone except Ted Cruz many men
were also offended by my use of the word
I do not care about that I should have
known that a potty mouth insult would be
inherently more interesting to them than
juvenile immigration policy if you are
worried about the death of civility
don't sweat it
I'm a comedian I am I'm really sorry
that I said that word but you know what
civility is just nice words maybe we
should all worry a little bit more about
the niceness of our actions okay I agree
with that but guess what her actions are
her show her words are her actions
that's all she does so first off let's
go through that real quick shed her
words never were intended hurt anyone
what about Ivanka well no you have taken
in contact okay
you called her a feckless in which
context was that designed to be anything
short of an insult then she goes I don't
care about them because men aren't
allowed to have opinions on someone
else's actions even if you're calling
said man's wife to c-word I guess then
she blames the news media cycle it's
true listen the media absolutely sucks
the news media the cable news outrage
cycle but so does she she's the one who
feeds into that she sources from
salon.com so she's kind of lost her leg
to stand on
then she closes it by putting on the
comedian hat which used to bother me a
lot about Jon Stewart and even even
Warren Trevor know even more when
Samantha B does it talking about how
matter more than words these are her
actions and here's the thing she hosts a
show in which they do nothing but feign
outrage I notice that right do you see
the irony here yeah absolutely terrible
and everything that she does apparently
can't even do this correct not that bad
about when she comes to lying about
statistical realities home
she's effective that's a really good
jacket for that one
they're brilliant to the left they owned
the media so they can just always go up
there and cover their own tracks just
like Bill Clinton is you see Bill
Clinton on Colbert where he basically
teed him up to apologize for all of his
comments about mama Liu I know that's
apologizing well she talks because I
know it's more interesting than Donald
Trump's asinine immigration policy
oh yes because samantha bee clearly
you're in the minority when it comes to
the media berating Trump over his
immigration policy you're the one
swinging you're swimming upstream right
that's what's happening here
you're risking it Samantha this is what
they always hold themselves out as
martyrs it's maybe you are the news
cycle you're a part of it's TBS I think
it Turner Broadcasting is if I'm not
mistaken as a parent company isn't it
the parent company they're us I think
Ted Turner
yeah he's riding on a bison giving money
with VNC and all this show constantly
demands apologies from people well now
they're providing a non-apology apology
so here's how an honest apology would
have been and I don't want an apology
from Samantha but no are using either
apologize or just be honest okay I got
caught I called the president's daughter
c-word yeah it was intended to be
hurtful I've done in the past I thought
I could continue to get away with it I'm
wrong sorry to those I deliberately
aimed to hurt or just don't apologize
either would be fine
offended I'm a little clueless here too
that she sucked at apologizing and she
said she wanted to reclaim the c-word I
don't know that's another thing what
does that mean I don't know even if it
meant you want to make that word cool
again was it ever cool well never how
much flack I got into not gauge when we
did that poster of Hillary Clinton [ __ ]
and we said [ __ ] is going to be the new
enemy down the back from fun [ __ ]
yeah I'm starting a lot of flack yeah we
still got a lot of [ __ ] we had the
picture of Hillary Clinton like the
Obama blue and red you can go back and
read the article great photos too
election was fantastic and we said this
election [ __ ] is going to be the new
n-word they're going and everyone who
was racist will wake up and all of a
sudden be considered a racist be
considered a sexist I apologize and
whose phone was that whose phone was
that Nightline oh you know what that was
Nightline that was that was my phone
anyway moving on from Samantha B let us
know what you think Seattle's homeless
10th mansion if those aren't that's the
term that's been coined is been growing
so much Department they even added a keg
party April and even though it's an
eyesore to neighbors and tour City
officials have said that the multi tent
encampment is a low priority for sweeps
so they felt comfortable enough to bring
over a keg to the site though they did
warn residents to not share beverages
also they posted a notice to those who
used the homeless tent mansion jacuzzi
should probably tested for AIDS really
you're being tested for not AIDS because
if you use the homeless tent mansion
jacuzzi and dodged that bullet we want
to know how sometimes you hold the Cure
identification is a good thing that's a
scratch that it's rate it's a great it's
expensive have a keg you get a rent the
machine like the equipment who's in the
tent city this homeless has money to go
get a keg who's prioritizing that to go
get the keg methadone yeah or Bud Light
Lime you know its craft don't bad Joe
give me that things I don't like feral
peacocks they're now attacking luxury
cars in British Columbia I think we have
some b-roll of this don't we have these
actual peacocks look there they've been
attacking it actually comes from CBS
News the Mustang not TP fowl they're
saying are taking property damage to a
whole new level they've been running
rampant throughout the town attacking
cars attacking buildings and some
thought this was actually due to the
peacocks mating season some actually
were blaming it of course in a clash
with urban sprawl is to see a lot until
the peacocks started hashtag peacocks
wives matter and now we see what their
true motive was I don't know how else it
could have ended up there organized they
her peacock deer a they're more they're
more organized than Shaun King yeah
alright more going on for them to better
funding yeah I still can't believe right
cuz about pocketing half of it movie an
Ontario teachers license by the way was
suspended for two months after she told
the student to okay I don't even I can't
even necessarily read this she told the
student quote lick me where I I'm
paraphrasing flatulate yeah she said
this teacher had her license young
student to lick me where I fart on my
way said Kevin Spacey
oh so happy I don't have this kind of
windows that's created though you got to
give her some credit this is a sweat
true story right Sven computer this is
true story from Mac well I mean but
here's the funniest part of that story I
didn't I I read through the article a
headline like it doesn't what doesn't
get any worse than this does it no no it
gets better among other things who
complained it quote she told another
student it sounds like your cheeks are
too close together the hallway don't
bother me she only got two I got papers
to correct I didn't get my star but we
thought it was funny to analyze this had
actually been an ongoing problem Dennis
it's a condition oh I mean it was always
difficult but when she brought out my
condition that was crossing the line
I've suffered was gluteous constructive
itís my whole life to be teased by
students there's one thing you know kids
are clean they called about a teacher
like that it's beyond your taste but the
student in question was diagnosed with
gluteus constrictive itis at age six and
despite all the teasing claims he was
beginning to make peace with it how
would I describe it um it's kind of like
an overbite for my ass to get fired in
in socialist country I don't understand
like what if that doesn't get it I don't
know what does well her license was
revoked I said but for like two months
I mean she's having the terrorist watch
list of probably the fastest way to get
a vacation is tell a child is a snack if
he should be offering to unlock her
phone this is somebody who no longer
cares an insult no here's the thing you
know this isn't the first most person
used it oh that's a go to your ass cheek
sound like a too close together like I
said it's great it will give her points
for that conehead
going to we're gonna have razor fist and
then Governor Mike Huckabee so here is
the the other outrage of the day because
this has been a jam-packed week for news
and then it's slowed down come Thursday
thank God for cultural appropriation
must go ah the Forbes 100 highest-paid
athletes list came out and there wasn't
a single woman on the list q outraged
well this is disappointing for the first
time ever no woman made Forbes list of
100 top paid athletes topping the list
were unsurprising names like Boyd
Mayweather Messi and Ronaldo okay so of
course instant complaints calling it a
damning indictment you see from leftist
and journalists this is gonna piss you
off a little bit because the highest
paid or soccer players and I thought
that would be you know a little you know
I usually would be upsetting justice of
it all but the end of day they still
live the rest of their life is soccer
[Laughter]
now the fight for equal pay in sports is
nothing new it's been going on for a
while now we've covered this these women
they train just as hard as the men do
you know we inspire as many young
players around the world as the men do
and so there's no reason why you need to
have a hundred you know two hundred to
one disparity in pay May it comes down
to simply a matter of inequity it's not
I mean women they are not paid the same
amount of money as blokes in so many
professions and I think we need to pay
women more in sport the women's soccer
team is taking legal action because they
want more players in the u.s. women's
national soccer team say they're being
discriminated against because they make
less than members of the men's team
okay well look even when the men's team
doesn't make the World Cup like
previously they still draw more people
than the women's team when they win do
you notice a lot of words that you hear
and there you hear all think apparently
you invented the language don't
pronounce your ths by the way I'll think
I deserve more women feel they you think
you want more I want I want you're
welcome for the movie as well actually
that one that one was underrated I know
I know you got flack for that but I
still think was pretty good here's the
thing athletes they don't ever talk
about earnings which is the key this is
what it is earnings athletes earnings
athletes get paid based on how much
money people pay to see them play and
people don't pay as much to see female
athletes people pay
Floyd Mayweather than Chris cyborg they
pepper wanted to see LeBron James and
they do hey Google who's the top player
in the WNBA see Siri seriously nobody
knows
Madonna understand and I know it was
because of your male privilege it's a
blind spot there are plenty berries
where women
far out except they excel well beyond
I'm going to say outperform men and I
said excel and it's like I had a break
this hat it's choose time under the Jews
are still so successful in every realm
of business and select create these
tight fight that and it's very hot I'm
quite certain I have lice I do we think
we've got the second hand from the
costume shop
can we storm is gonna cut the section
I'll be like CES I knew he was Jewish
your complain like a morphine drip look
at the Forbes top list of paid models
they're all women all of them they've
always been women and this is what we're
saying earlier about mrs. Amit mrs.
America I'm going now yesterday's that
occur visa my mrs. America isn't you
think she needs a man celebrates women's
bodies because they're beautiful they
celebrate women because they're
beautiful generally men are only
celebrated for their functionality now
it's not that a man can't have an
attractive body or face and it's not
that a woman can't be functional it's
just that men naturally tend to excel at
being the biggest fastest strongest what
women tend to naturally excel at being
far more beautiful than a sweaty hairy
guy is hanging about who's the most
popular because I mean you can argue
Ronda Rousey is popular but but no one's
watching her stuff and athletically even
the weakest NBA players can mop the
floor with her right Kevin Kevin Durant
for instance I'm sure you can you know
when he's not spending this money and
time do stigmatizing in a friend of the
show Andrew Bogut
Anja Morgan give him six weeks of
training yep watch ride I'll see tough
girl thing or an angry lesbian Brazilian
named Amanda Nunez perfect
so you're just men are gonna do they're
gonna do better in paid sports well
women tend to dominate fashion glamor
modeling industries now your
thing but when you find the outrage at
women not being the top athletes list
it's it's it's it's this desire to
completely erase the differences between
men and women this is what we've been
talking about this is what everyone else
out there knows
have you noticed by the way YouTube's
bizarre obsession with [ __ ] makeup
tutorials on the Trinity there's like
one style there's one genre of makeup
one tutorial should do because it's in
tandem what there's a real push for
[ __ ] cover girls trainee Playboy
Playmates trainee women of the male
women of the year what's so funny as we
talked about this and some of the the
angry left us atheists on Twitter like
oh those two annual no search history no
it's not dummy I'm not saying it's the
trending list on YouTube yeah yeah it's
like make us already and [ __ ] with
Rouge I don't know why they're pushing
on us it's I think I do it's the same
idea they want to push men into this
female dominated industry just like they
want equality of outcome with women in
sports they well they want equality of
opportunity we thought you can either
have a quality of opportunity or you can
have equality and outcomes right that's
it you cannot have both yeah and you
always want equality of opportunity
that's the only exact number one just a
fair shot to do what you do
equality of outcome results when you
have things like a permit of action we
have things like specific cop
scholarships for race or gender what
happens it actually removes the
opportunity the fair opportunity to
someone who can earn it to give it to
someone where it is unearned equal
outcomes look let's use this analogy
here in sports okay if we say you know
what there's only 500 million dollars
for soccer I know there's far more but
let's go with what it deserves there's
only five dollars in soccer okay if they
separate at two dollars and fifty cents
equally to the men and the women when
the women lose to highschool boys teams
and people don't want to watch them play
was balloons I mean that means there's
going to be far less money for the sport
that would be profitable where men
deserve the opportunity to earn their
keep they don't get the opportunity to
earn it equal outcomes cannot ensure
equal outcomes cannot result in equal
opportunity and I don't know women in
sports is this is such a perfect example
of the free market at work because even
women don't want to watch other women in
sports it's not a thing it's nothing and
that's why that's also where you had the
left pushing people like like like
scouts go handsome who sucks and
Avengers or other or blind
what is her superpower she has a
superpower but they have to date they'd
love it because that's the only the
fantasy world is the only way they can
kick a man's ass what is it
[Laughter]
any superpower she's just there okay she
had a hard childhood her superpower she
made the caste income and the prestige
that's right back into Miss America
right we're saying it should be about
personality intelligence I was thinking
if that's the case great just give it to
Betty White
if you sharper than any of those girls
and that's why it's not fair again this
is to remove the essence of what makes a
human storm asleep with her someone like
Winston Churchill but we're talking
about he's never gonna want beauty
contests now so instead he uses his
Winston Churchill Ness his intellect and
his wit to be successful kick-ass by the
same token Miss America is never going
to be Winston Churchill but now we're
demanding that she tried to be Winston
Churchill because for her to not be
Winston Churchill is actually sexist
even though she signed up to walk six
steps in a bikini it's not that
confusing I mean why would they do in
trying to force equal outcomes you end
up eliminating what makes people who
they are so beauty and physical strength
are both forms of power and this is why
ugly feminists hate beautiful women and
weak men hate stronger men and the women
who like strong men so instead of trying
to be more attractive instead of trying
to get stronger so left does what it
does they try to demonize achievement
whether it's beauty or strength
some people are beautiful some people
have great personalities for some it's
great physical prowess not all people
are born with all the things and that's
okay I've tried well in every every time
you do equal outcomes you get rid of
greatness because you have to bring
other people down nobody can be great
anymore nobody can be super beautiful or
can be LeBron James and I hate him
whatever fine right you own a jet start
hating them LeBron day oh no I know but
you've said some bad stuff about him in
the past we know about that what you're
mad at him now
no I just think no no no I met all of
Cleveland you should always be mad at
all of Cleveland no I really mean it I
lived there it's the only sane thing you
can do it's like saying I've been
disappointed in Detroit this quarter
yeah the tipping point they removed the
Coney Island I liked
manners they're just better at
performing at higher levels when it
comes to athletics mm-hmm don't believe
a greeter brought this up look it we
have the actual overlay here of what
happens when they go head to head with
boys 15-year old dad pretty 15 year old
boyfriend computer yes I'm the 15 year
olds even so you put a bit on that team
and there's nothing wrong there's
nothing wrong with that okay there's a
lot wrong with that what means there's
nothing wrong with accepting that men
are better at certain things including
athletics just like just like by the way
it's okay to accept that women are
better at certain things and this is the
Miss America the Forbes listen to
complaints it's the exact same complaint
you see from the left as you do with
Bernie Sanders as you do with black
lives matter as you do with [ __ ] had
economics it's just people screaming
everyone has to be special son of a
[ __ ] every what now when everyone's
special right seeing credit Bernie
Sanders needs to watch The Incredibles
gretchen carlson needs to watch The
Incredibles anyone mad about the fact
that women are not making more than
Floyd Mayweather arguably the best
defensive boxer of all time
neat adjust what's being credited Eclair
to be special then nobody is you want
you were so concerned about correcting
papers with a red pen now that it's
banned in certain states and provinces
because it might hurt someone's
self-esteem but let's not actually
acknowledge a kid for an area where he's
talented let's tell him they're all you
what helps a kids self-esteem you know
what helps a girls self-esteem or a boys
self-esteem is finding what they're
great at discouraging what they suck at
or what is destructive and pushing them
on down that path you can't do that when
you're guaranteeing equal outcomes we'll
talk more about that after the break
with DeWitt two razörfist and then I
think governor Mike Mike the governor
Mike Huckabee raise your fist effort
what do you say you're shooting with the
Rockets while I'm doing the monologue
what do you think would happen
[Music]
Marco come join the MUX press when they
pull the beer only I own all the banks
so our next guests always a fit one of
my favorite guests on the show and I'm
hoping that him appearing on the show
more people are going and checking out
his youtube channel he's on the Twitter
at raised or fist with a zero and I'm
trying about what his YouTube is very
hard for me to remember but mister fist
what's your YouTube channel exactly
again extremely convoluted URL it's
youtube.com slash see for some reason
slash the rageaholic
I don't know well let's try and
consolidate that at some point and maybe
you won't be so rageful but David if
only there were a vast conspiracy I can
blame my yeah I know I don't know I just
blame the YouTube moderators they've
usually done something wrong and they'll
fess up to it even if they even if they
haven't done anything oh yeah I probably
did do that sounds like me you guys you
guys can call me Rosen fists razor Blatt
yes steam
I'll be I'll be conducting this
interview from within triple sets of
parentheses yes it's razor fists Blatt
Steenburgen and married to Ted Danson I
don't know how that works out but it
seems like they're they they all are
yeah hey razor fist you did a video
recently on on Joe McCarthy and I know
this this caught up caught up caught on
sorry this is catching up with me I'm
getting a little bit heated here explain
to people why you thought that was
important because I know you do a lot of
you know you do a lot of video game
stuff you've sort of got more into
cultural commentary McCarthyism right is
a term that's thrown around quite a bit
it's lost all meaning right no actually
was originally about it was sort of more
about how Hollywood communism
infiltrated the entire sort
area and how it relates to current
California politics and really how
people today have conflated McCarthyism
and Hollywood communism right the whole
hearings thing which they're actually
two distinct things because it was times
that's one thing people don't realize
sometimes they were right in spotting
communists well and that's the thing
after the fall of the Berlin Wall after
it went you know split ski they found
they uncovered all these communique
they were reprinted in several books
actually the Soviet world of American
communism by Harvey Clair John Earl
Haynes and Carol Anderson I believe they
actually reprinted word-for-word that
communicates and you found out that
apparently the Soviet Union were funding
the American Communist Party including
the Hollywood communist party to the
tune of between a third and one half of
their overall operating budget like yeah
they were just Hollywood alone they were
dropping at least 2 mil annually you
know the same amount like an American
politician spends on ads every four
years except they were doing it every
year or ass if your bill yeah it depends
well that's all the expense budget
either way taxpayers foot the bill yeah
so okay so and that ties into so you did
this video how they recommend people go
check it out at sea slash raged the
rageaholic but that ties into obviously
the California Senate run I mean it's
kind of really with California outside
of the Arnold issue when it comes to
state politics when it comes to a state
legislature and of course the House and
Senate it's which Democrat is really
going to win or Republican deep in their
name effectively well yeah but like how
badly did Jerry Brown have to put up as
governor to get a Republican within six
points of victory in California it's
like that that state is bluer than
Jared's balls over there if you put you
you could put a D next to Trump's name
they'd elect him King without even
checking yeah how do you how do you even
do that what did he hide their hash
brownies like how does that even work in
the state of California there was an
article that someone just try think of
the New York Times had tried to pass it
off as though it was a great state for
business it's actually not and if you
remove Silicon Valley it's not growing
at all and I think la for the first time
seen population stagnation if not
decline relatively speaking I don't have
the numbers in front of me but compared
to Texas and you have a lot of
Californians moving from California in
businesses you have a state yeah but a
Liberty Mutual to Texas but then they
bring their policies there I so I really
just think it comes down to Californians
are often [ __ ] yes I'm speaking of
Jewish appropriation it's you know it's
a mass exodus that's what it is they get
here and they start instead of bitching
about man are they gonna start bitching
about more the thing that blows me away
is like even though DNC numbers are down
like did you see what some of these in
particularly the entrenched California
Democrats like won by these these dudes
are pulling down like South American
dictator numbers yeah like you know like
oh what's that Feinstein you won by one
thousand and five percent oh yeah that's
that's not that's not fishier than
stormy Daniels in a song right we get
where this is going
I think I think I could under you after
you said stormy I was like this can only
end one way so okay what do you expect
what do you think is gonna happen with
California you've been covering this
quite a bit or you're interested in it
quite a bit do you think California
rights the ship or do you think it just
crashes itself into oblivion eventually
well come on like like I said they will
elect literally anything with the DMX
and their name I mean they they
reelected Gerry Jonestown Browne you
know what I mean like anyone
this guy's spoke at Jim Jones's church
he appointed Jim Jones illegally the
housing Commissioner of San Francisco a
thousand dead commies in you know the
worst pinko potluck in human history and
30 years later they reelect the guy
because apparently pull pot was booked
you think this is a state that's turning
it around no no it's going to be the
state equivalent of Detroit which is sad
because of all the rich natural
resources I mean it really should be
when they say well California is
actually still the fifth biggest economy
in the world like well it's it's a
coastal state with more resources than
any state ever the funniest story to me
we were just talk about it this week
the for those who are my club members to
me the funniest story which I believe
crystallizes California perfectly is
when Tom Selleck was charged with
stealing water for his avocado farm I
just thought that's Tom Selleck stealing
well he doesn't even like avocados
that's a fascinating thing I don't even
know what I was doing siphoning it I
think he was putting it in trucks but
it's like in California's like if you
guys just didn't dam everything up if
you if you guys allowed yourselves to
actually use the water so you're so
close to the border you can your
guacamole there how else are you gonna
grow that how else do you grow that
magnificent mustache you know you need a
sod farm under there you got a nourish
yet I think about tap this conversation
basically in California in the matter of
have a Dean next your name in San
Francisco a D in your take whatever your
pick is here
what's your thought on the on the folder
just tell them of this earlier I would
imagine you have a lot of thoughts on
this because it's kind of more cultural
social people complaining that no female
athletes are amongst the top paid in
Forbes 100 and they've removed the
bikini and I was the evening gown from
Miss America it's been a crapstorm of
just destroying the idea that women can
be beautiful this week it really is when
I would I heard that I naturally assumed
the the fix was in for Amy Schumer but
then I remembered there was a there was
actually a talent portion so now sadly
good Laura you are unless unless shrill
as a talent
yes well or you're like a barnyard
animal and tagging that with the exact
same joke 15 times no I mean that's what
we were telling earlier if it's if it's
about intellect if it's about
personality I'm sending Betty White she
I mean she just cleans house you know
that's it's a beauty pageant well that's
the thing if I want to watch some broad
tell me what charity she donates to and
you know listen to her demonstrate
Tibetan throat singing I could always
date an anthropology major you know it's
not it's not hard they're all over cat
moms calm or whatever the hell you say
that I had I thought it was I forgot
it's Tibetan throat singing or Mongolian
throat saying it is Tibet yeah I had a
cabdriver in Los Angeles I can do it do
Tibetan throat sing and he wanted me to
do it was like the mm-hmm like do it do
it with me it's kind of going yeah it's
basically whistling and humming at the
same time and it sounds
like when Jim Carrey in Dumb and Dumber
said tractor beam mmm
I had a cabdriver who would not let me
off the hook without Tibetan throat
singing so why do you know about it Wow
well you see I have a past at a Tibetan
monastery yeah I can imagine a lot you
don't know about me but it is it is I
mean here's a view we were just talking
with have you ever sat down because all
the top models paid are women if you
were sat down and been angry and said
why are these women being paid so much
money to be in the cover of these
magazines and gotten bitter about it
yeah I don't know about you but my head
doesn't hit the pillow at night without
thinking about you know how much Cindy
Crawford was paid for that she Doritos
commercial or Elle Macpherson for her
poor performance in the edge that's the
only film it's still a positive let's be
honest but she wasn't great that was a
really specific reference because I tell
you what when I was a kid it was al
McPherson in the edge I was I was all
about DL McPherson the BOD she was known
apparently perfect dimensions could you
imagine that nowadays she was known as
the BOD because she had the perfect
dimensions which by the way we're not
sin she wasn't a sin girl she was more
of a kiddin type and men loved her she
was six-foot wasn't me and almost almost
like it's a pageant or something you
know I mean like can you imagine this
metric being applied anywhere else else
on God's green earth you know any other
pageant like welcome to the Westminster
Dog Show where we'll be handing out
first prize ribbons if you lick your
balls and chase a laser pointer you know
what I mean like it doesn't really work
that way you you you're supposed to
stand there and linger your hand
uncomfortably near my dogs balls for
forty-five minutes okay that's a new it
like a normal pass best-case scenario an
old lady sticks to sum up the dog's ass
[Music]
well you know it's not so much about
purebred so we're gonna do it with
rescues and it's just some pug that
comes out with a missing eye or some
some border collie that looks like it
was blown up in the Mexican American War
yeah I don't know I I just I don't
understand well I understand it I
understand it completely okay well we do
have to get going what is it that you
would want people to check out most in
your channel this thing if we have to go
back to it the McCarthy issue why
check it out yeah that that video it's
actually called Hollywood was always
read it's more about the Hollywood
communism hearings Ronald Reagan factors
in there it's sort of the history of how
communism infiltrated Hollywood in the
20s 30s and 40s and how that was brought
to light and how sort of modern
Hollywood has been left the custodians
of the narrative of it and so it's been
conflated into this makar theists
witch-hunt kind of counter narrative
that isn't really accurate at all and
what kind of pushback did you receive
for this video
pushback you get a backhoe plenty plenty
I'm making friends all over the world
I'm like Billy Idol's dick in any part
of the world might have worked in I
don't know 92 I'm trying to think of
back when it would have when it would
have been relevant no I am I think a lot
of what what inspired you to do this
video because it's not something that's
incredibly topical and it's something
that I've we've talked about on here
before I know there are books on this I
think not who's not the white supremacy
is the other one which one's a white
supremacist Richard Spencer Robert
Spencer Richard Spencer okay Robert
Spencer is the one who I think wrote a
book on it the politically incorrect
guide to Hollywood communism but what
inspired you to write this to do this
recently I read a lot of books about it
that inspired me to originally I was
just gonna do sort of a quick TED minute
rants you know about the house on
American Activities Committee by the end
it had ballooned into this half hour
you know anti-bolshevik barrage thing
you you have no idea how expensive
Pinochet's helicopter is to rent no
freaking I guess yeah but no Hollywood
party by Kenneth Lloyd Billingsley is a
really good book to pick up on that it's
a good overview is written in around 97
I know Ann Coulter wrote one more about
McCarthy called treason I want to say
and there's a number of pretty
blacklisted from history I think is
another McCarthy book some good ones but
mostly it was about the house on
American Activities Committee which
actually had nothing to do with McCarthy
rat all know that's a good point
actually it's funny I know people gonna
say oh so Denny Coulter loses all
credibility people actually go back to
Ann Coulter's writing specifically
earlier on she was meticulous about
sourcing about referencing doesn't mean
she was always right she
was always working to stay in there and
this was before the whole kind of
becoming effectively a cheerleader for
Trump a lot of people aren't aware that
she was really a fantastic writer and
did her due diligence all right that is
on the Twitter at razörfist with a zero
right now k jerry-san
on the youtube / c / the rageaholic a
rageaholic the rage Alex we're gonna
point people towards this video I hope
they learn up on it and I hope you are
heavily armed sir hi what live root of
the week listen if you enjoy cultural
appropriation month and other
festivities at YouTube would never allow
natively on its platform please do join
it louder with credit com / mug let me
get access to the entire CR TV lineup
this wonderful hand etch mug for $99 69
annually if your student better
interactive military and of course you
get the Daily Show it's what keeps this
channel going because no one knows
what's gonna happen with YouTube or
social media in the future also if you
don't want to join up at mug Club
because you're a cheap bastard you can
support our sponsors we only have a
handful the biggest one has been Walter
for a long time they were up to listen
by the way for those who are looking
earlier this was a an airsoft gun so
Walter I highly recommend for a home
defense pistol there ppq this is a
replica of that as an airsoft gun with
which I shot the Palestinian terrorists
earlier and I think it was it murex
Morang boomer X Y after looking for
airsoft guns - not only a pistol lead
there they're really good quality
accurate what Walter does everything
very well yes and that's the thing but
it makes really easy for a sponsor of
ours a lot of you I know are going
through this and a lot of you're saying
hey what should I do for my first
firearm ok they have their ppq that's
this their full size that their PPS to
carry and then they have one that's in
between all we all we ask is that if you
go to a shooting range understand they
have the balls to support the show where
a lot of firearm
companies are afraid they actually play
ball with the left Walter stepped up
they support the show and we just ask go
out and try when you go to shooting
range see if it's not that right try the
Glock try this myth and Wesson trial
them try the Walther and we're pretty
confident about the choice we made in
our sponsorship so mug Club Walter those
are the two big ones enjoy the show
[Music]
I don't know where that someone can
tweet me a discretion policy I don't
know what hadouken means either they
could be saying something incredibly
profane in that video game and I play it
and you know kids play you have no idea
no idea no idea that's what needs our
ratings in our culture we did Japan last
year we missed that boat our next guest
I very much appreciate that he's come on
the show and I know he's not feeling
that well so you can fight he's been on
the show many times you can follow mitt
gov Mike Huckabee he's the host of
course 8 and 11 on TV another so
Huckabee Governor Mike Huckabee thanks
for being here sir hey Steven great to
be with you and I hope you forgive me
for not dancing the Shalom special there
but I'll have to take you up on another
opportunity that's okay why I hear it
sounds like you're at death's door with
your I would I had a bronchial thing or
is it pneumonia no I think it's just
flying in so many airplanes in that
cabin air yeah it's drier than the Gobi
Desert so I feel fine I just have lost
my voice and maybe it's screaming at the
television because occasionally I'll
flip over to CNN or MSNBC and I found
myself uncontrollably yelling at the
screen which I've got to stop doing that
I was going to say I mean if people
don't know what's going on your
neighbors are just gonna be saying well
it's that point he was very sharp and
now he's senile we never thought I was
gonna happen when governor Mike but here
we go it happens yeah it happens I feel
the same we have to reach the lawn in
HuffPo everyday we have to repeat we
threw leftist sources more than
conservatives to try and know what
they're saying and I know you've always
done you've always been we've talked
about this with you on the show you've
only been so formidable in debate you've
always been very um straightforward you
don't shy away from what you believe but
polite and we try to talk about that
there's a way to be civil but you don't
have to lie about finding common ground
where there isn't any why do you think
so many people miss that they think it's
one or the other nowadays that was
something I've always wanted to ask you
you know I think it's Steven it's simple
a lot of people don't take God seriously
but they take themselves incredibly
seriously right my view is don't take
yourself too seriously take God
seriously and and don't ever think that
the whole world is all about cells but
you know when people get their feelings
hurt over everything
it's really an indication that they have
such a focus upon themselves
they really are narcissists right and
people need a sense of humor so I love
your show you've got a sense of humor
well and not everybody likes it you know
because the left goes nuts because you
know you poke holes very legitimate
Drive I didn't want to go I know what if
what if you're like Kanye and you're the
black Jesus then I guess you have to
just take it all seriously because you
are God hey I wanted to ask you
something that I know is been in the
news and will be near and dear to your
heart something I think you could
provide some insight on that Alice
Johnson sir just yeah right as I talk
about something serious this hat lops
over like et the community of the
sentence of Alice Johnson by President
Donald Trump we haven't really heard a
lot about this in the media black woman
who was there for nonviolent drug
related charges and even to deal with
this obviously as governor tell us what
what what your view is on this situation
right now and why hasn't it gotten more
coverage it would seem as though it's
something that is a happy all around
story everyone want to hear well here's
the fact if a conservative like Donald
Trump issues a commutation to an
african-american woman who clearly had a
disproportionate sentence for her crime
yes it was a first-time offense
nonviolent and she gets life without
parole I cannot begin to tell you how
excessive a sentence that is Stephen
most people who are convicted of murder
will end up serving seven or eight years
right that's just a fact some will have
maybe a life sentence but get out after
a you know a number of years right life
without parole is the kind of sentence
that you give to somebody if they've
murdered a cop if they have raped and
dismembered a child it is not when you
give to a great-grandmother by the way
she's already served 22 years of the
sentence she has lost that much now a
lot of people say well you know what the
we've got to be tough on crime I get
that sure but we should not be so tough
on people and and I'll put it to you
this way my prison director when I was
governor great guy named Larry Norris
and he used to say we're locking up a
lot of people that were bad
rather than the ones we are afraid of
right and I think that really settles it
because look it caused probably in the
neighborhood of $35,000 a year in a
federal lockup for the taxpayers now I'd
have to ask as a taxpayer how many of us
are really excited about locking up
great-grandmother's for a crime
committed 23 years ago adjudicated 22
years ago and are still being in prison
for no particular valid reason after all
this time I don't imagine maybe like
Bill Cosby to draw some press off
himself I'm thinking you're giving her a
universal income would actually be
cheaper it would actually be cheaper
well you don't want to conflate the
issues because the left they've been so
wrong about some of these these
sentences wanting full pardons rubber
Tookie Williams and they were
complaining to arnold schwarzenegger
when this guy well this guy was actually
one of the founding members of either
the bloods of the Crips had killed I
think four people in three different
shootings and refused to his entire life
give up information regarding other
members of the gang but he wrote a
children's book so everyone was
campaigning saying well you need to make
the phone call this guy I think he had
the death penalty if I'm not mistaken
and this was very different and well on
a second it's one thing to write a
children's book on how to avoid gang
violence it's another thing to actually
save children's lives if you could give
up the names of people who are out there
still killing this wasn't one of those
cases I encourage people to go read up
more on them on the Johnson case and
have you had some situations like this
for you to do this as governor oh
absolutely
and it's a tough call I mean I had a
thousand cases a year that would come to
my desk carried out the death penalty
more than any governor in the history of
the state not something that I would
take any pleasure in because it's a
horrible horrible thing to have to do
but I also probably issued a record
number of commutations not as many
outright pardons and there's a
difference a lot of people use that term
interchangeably very different but
Steven here's the reason a lot of people
who don't know really quickly I know you
don't really don't know pardon the
basically erases the conviction Hardin
says you're no longer a felon you can
vote you can buy guns it's as if you
never come into the crime commutation
reduces the sentence and most of the
time a commutation reduces it to time
served in her
okay she walked out the door in some
cases you commute to a specific term
let's say a person has been given 60
years they've served five you commute it
down to ten and maybe they serve two
more years and then they get out on
parole so there's a lot of different all
of it is under the banner of clemency
right but what I was going to point out
is that you know a lot of liberals say
that they believe in sentencing reform
that is until a conservative actually
does one I can tell you there's no
political upside to Donald Trump having
done this
the Conservatives a lot of them will be
mad at him and the Liberals will never
ever not one time give him any credit
for looking at this african-american
grandmother great-grandmother and
stepping in and writing injustice in the
disproportionate sentence so you know I
experienced this when I would do one
that people say oh you need to you know
commute the sentence I'd do it and guess
who beat me up the most the left yeah
because they didn't want me to get
credit for having a heart they wanted to
say the Conservatives you know hate
people especially minorities and that's
not true and that is you they invent the
term compassionate conservative well I'm
a compassionate conservative implying
that all other conservatives or what I
just said no no I'm a conservative don't
don't hit me well but final question on
this and I want to move on to the
Philadelphia Eagles let me ask you this
because in Sweden they basically get
glorified apartments right for prison do
you think that prison should be more
about punishment or rehabilitation
because in Europe it's so far the other
way where it's almost not a punishment
some of these countries and the United
States a lot of them don't get
rehabilitated and that's one issue where
I've talked about go back and forth I
think they need to be punished but I
don't know the system works well I can
assure you that when you lose your
freedom it is a punishment and you know
people used to say all these people in
prison they've got it so so well so good
well they don't
I've been to every prison in my state
and always said if you ever hear that
I've committed the crime and it's a
state crime I guarantee it's a lie
because I would never do something that
would subject me to spending one night
in one of our prisons I random I knew
them well I would never want to be there
if I commit a crime by gosh it's federal
because they're a lot better in their
prisons but but having said that be
selective there you go that's nice right
governor Mike Huckabee says be selective
in your crime committed you're gonna
commit a crime before shadow do ever do
a federal offense but you know I think
what we have to recognize is that the
real goal ought to be correction I mean
that's the goal we have with our own
children isn't it right if our children
do something that's wrong it's not that
we want to punish them because we get
some delight in watching them suffer our
delight comes when their behavior is
corrected now in order to do that in the
really penal system the necessity is
making sure that whatever adjudication
is given it not only fits the crime but
it has the best likelihood of bringing
the in the outcome to be some level of
correction let me give you an example
Stephen 88% of all the inmates in the
Arkansas prison system are there for a
drug or alcohol related crime they were
either drunk or high when they committed
the crime or they come into the crime to
get drunk or high yeah put that into
focus what we need is not more people
locked up we need more people who are in
some type of effective treatment program
that gets them out of the drug and
alcohol addiction and I'll be very blunt
with you the only programs that I've
seen effectively work are faith-based
programs and those have to be voluntary
for the inmate you can't force people
into a faith-based program but it's the
only thing that works because these are
people messed up on the inside and you
can't just change their behavior by
reconditioning it's a vicious cycle like
you said they're either they're either
doing it because you're drunk or higher
doing it to get drunk riots it's the
Wild Turkey or the egg so they can get
drunken yeah exactly I know someone who
they're their relative I will not say
who what this person knows who they are
went to the insane asylum a long time
ago and she was so manipulative and so
difficult to open the door and said
please leave you are free to go so
hopefully a little bit better than
speaking of insane let me ask this to
Philadelphia I was a I was about to say
fliers because I'm a Canadian guy hockey
guy let's say Philadelphia Flyers no way
Philadelphia Eagles the white house you
said you would have handled that
situation a little bit differently
I'm curious what what's your take on
this well let me first of all say the
Eagles tried to set the president up for
an embarrassment right you know the
whole team was invited they all cleared
security and then it became known then
when he got down to it only one of the
Eagles maybe two or three would have
even shown up and so it would have been
an embarrassing situation not just for
the president but for the Eagles they
didn't care they wanted it to be that
but what I suggested was I think the
president should have said you know as
many of you as want to come come on and
then show them the time of their lives
give them all kinds of white house swag
take them up to the private quarters
walk them through the whole problem you
know the whole facility yeah
and absolutely make it the best day of
their lives and let them go back and say
my gosh the president treated me like a
king you know I think it would have been
a great way to do the totally unexpected
thing and in politics I subscribe to the
view do what people least expect you to
do push them back on their heels and
never give them the the pleasure of you
know having you do what they thought you
would do but they are professional
football players so it would be pretty
hard to exceed expectations at this
point your multi multi millionaires they
need some swag maybe if they had like a
like like if Donald a president Donald
Trump had a water slide from his bedroom
going out to the pool like in blank
check you know he does that does he have
it wouldn't surprise ya my daughter she
takes her kids on that water slide off
straight for the rube right to the pool
though said touches this gold okay it
would be they would go back and they
would say listen it was it was a lot of
fun I do wish she just wouldn't have
made it so public I just would have not
said anything and invited another team
it would have been happy to come and
then have them there there are multitude
of ways I can handle it I do like your
idea your show is on TBN on Saturdays at
8:00 and 11:00 right now it's called try
to be is that deep down was your other
show called Huckabee it was we couldn't
come up with a better name okay I'll
tell you the show is very similar except
we're doing it in Nashville okay we have
an amazing studio
big theater we have about a thousand
people that come be part of the show
Wow and it's enough politic Stephen as
you remember from my Fox show that it's
fun but we do a lot of things that are
not being done on TV anymore
we've got comedians acrobats a lot of
music of course we're in Nashville right
you're gonna have music on the show and
it's a fun wholesome entertaining
variety show I think people will enjoy
it and you know true as much time
anymore in that cesspool of where dreams
go to die in New York City it spend more
time in I do not go there very much
which I'm much rather go to Nashville
every week well you know maybe we'll
come out sometime out to the live studio
audience and do a do a show here on this
show about your show it'll be like it'll
be like Inception the show's within the
shows and we'll bring out Yakov Smirnoff
and have him tell like a few Gio I love
it thank you at gov Mike Huckabee you
can watch the show on TV and 8:00 and
11:00 thank you so much governor go heal
up drink some honey tea
[Music]
a long long time ago
I can still remember when contestants
used to wave and smile
but I knew if feminists had their way
they would make the whole thing gay and
Miss America would be a trans queer
fatty named Kyle the news cycle filled
me with dread with every blog post that
I read beauty is now seen as unfair it's
all about acne and green hair I can't
imagine what they meant when they said
there'd be no swimsuit event they said
that it was cuz it was obscene but we
all know it was to hide the [ __ ]
wings so bye bye Miss America's thighs
drove my Prius with no weenus singing me
too or die and the gender studies boys
were drinking soy and crime gender roles
are patriarchal lie they scream gender
roles are a patriarchal line
so bye-bye miss Americas lives drove my
previous without no weenus hashtag me
too or die and the gender studies boys
were drinking soy and crime
maybe gender roles are are patriarchal I
next Miss America will be David Hogg
[Music]
[Music]
does hair float I don't know no I was
too busy re-enacting jaws talk about
narcissus you're both in our own world
here thank you so much to razörfist
thank you so much to Governor Mike
Huckabee and our apologies to sargon of
akkad we'll have him back on soon thank
you to Owen Benjamin of course follow
him on at least on Twitter but on
YouTube at Owen Benjamin comedy has some
tour dates coming up yep and we have
some big change my mind's coming up soon
we're gonna rattling off a few of them
including one for fourth of July and
hope we'll see what happens with a
hidden camera situation we've been
working on for a little bit and those
are hit or miss so a lot of work going
on behind the scenes and yeah you were
you were you were about to say what I'm
saying earlier was before your point
that's what I was thinking I'm afraid of
wet hair since the ring ran here at all
I remember that trick was the ring in
The Grudge oh you wanna make movie scary
to have a dead girl with what hair yeah
yeah i-i'll try my hair before I go to
bed I can't sleep with the wet hair I
can't do anything your hair yeah you
blow-dry your hair
yeah every day okay go on with your
point there as though people are still
lifting can take off the glasses by the
way no cage air has been a trooper there
are no lines oh I thought the real NZ
said you couldn't see anything
oh you can't because you don't have your
glass yeah exactly oh oh there's your
face my point was that it just becomes
clearer and clearer every day that left
hate success they really freaking it
with the Forbes list with we talked
about with Israel a huge success Miss
America they hate success everywhere it
could be found they want everyone and I
remember even like we talked about the
underdog you know they believe that the
underdog always has the moral high
ground the underdog is granted moral
superiority with the left now I don't
not every single but we're talking about
the left as a whole people like and
Samantha these are the world leaders
have left the DNC the media
establishment
yeah they do they grant moral
superiority to the underdog yeah if
you're if you're an ugly fat feminist
you were granted moral superiority over
the woman who trained day and night and
got ready for tonight their time to
charity see right exactly because she's
pretty because she's pretty yeah I even
like that I think about the movie Rudy
like I think most of us grew up with
that thinking
oh wow what an inspirational story they
got older I'm like that's gonna be yes
didn't really deserve that it's a
feel-good story because everyone else
feel sympathetic form because he worked
really hard but the truth is it would
have meant more if he'd have earned his
spot and you know what Rudy could it
maybe earned his spot somewhere else
yeah yeah and what's funny is like yeah
I can't think of there's times in my
life where I was giving given something
that I knew I didn't earn and it felt
like one instance was but I went to UM I
went to a guitar it was like a showcase
kind of thing and I did a guitar solo
classical talk I'm awful at classic
guitar yeah songs I did it in high
school and I didn't practice I didn't
want to practice I was all flat I didn't
I skip my half of my lessons for it and
I went and did this in front of this
really intimidating judge and I botched
it he gave me a chance in the middle to
restart the whole thing which she didn't
have to do I did the whole thing and I
got to the end were there passing out
the awards with everybody else and I'm
thinking like oh my gosh all the friends
every every person I've ever had a crush
on this year and I'm going to just melt
when they give me an honorable mention
gave me a blue ribbon and III of relief
but then I went home I'm like I didn't
post it anywhere I didn't put it on my
board I didn't put up a hanging above my
bed cuz I knew I knew like that was BS
yeah I shouldn't have gotten the blue
ribbon it doesn't feel good they'll get
it all know what
Babla mail it's a fox news well they are
me I was 21 I was the youngest country I
knew I knew I knew they didn't know how
young I was but I knew it was just
because I was sort of young comedian
something they hadn't had before I had
spanked Alan Colmes on air in a debate
but I knew that I didn't there were
other people more deserving of that spot
every when I got it I was happy but then
I worked in contrast I worked so hard
when I was there I moved to New York
City with no guarantees by the way it
was like you were paid for parents and
then it ended up being like it's kind of
you know paltry retainer when I worked
for those who are coming in a lot of
people know that was a Fox News for four
and a half years as an on-air
contributor Hannity Fox and Friends read
I I mean all the shows all the shows
except O'Reilly yeah literally and I
worked so hard when I was there and I
feel and hosted and then they had Fox
News I think was Studio B it was it was
an online thing the Fox News strategy
room and far fewer people watched that
than watch this program and I worked so
hard and showed up for the early
segments no one wanted to do I remember
two new years in a row I had to be up at
3:00 a.m. because I was in Central Time
with that pole
and I was having to do it by satellite
and they had me do the first hour of Fox
and Friends and I worked so hard
just trying to get something off the
ground because at that point they were
looking at doing some weekend
programming and it didn't matter I was
literally told listen it's just not
gonna happen we're either gonna rerun
O'Reilly and cheaper we're already
paying them and if you look at their
programming but it was just rerunning
the state they would do Bill O'Reilly I
think Hannity Greta just and they would
rerun all of them like twice really so
it didn't matter what I did or how good
I was
it's free it's free you feel another
[ __ ] sorry it's already paid for
country yeah so when I got it I didn't
deserve it I felt I felt bad and then
when I really I knew that I gave it
everything I had and it wasn't given the
shot that they said yeah you deserve
we're just not doing that right now
you know yep what would have been better
for me what would have been much much
better is to give me the honorable
mention let me deal with the
embarrassment now I'm gonna come back
the next year and blown everyone out of
the water yeah what I would have gone
home like you know what nothing that's
not gonna happen again
right because I know I knew I was better
than what I put into it but I didn't
earn it yeah would've been better for me
to not get any kind of mention at all
everyone out there is good at some long
time to find out when the left says
believe in yourself you're perfect the
way you are and we don't champion that
cause we say well hold a second you're
not perfect the way you are and
sometimes maybe you shouldn't believe in
yourself but the left doesn't want you
to believe in yourself know what you
feel what you feel good in the moment
they want you to feel good about they
want everyone to feel good but it's okay
believe in yourself oh oh you know what
I think that I would be a really good
Miss America this is no no no no we
can't have that believe in yourself you
know what I think I think I could become
it and be off so it wasn't no no we need
to have a certain amount of money from
and everyone needs to be the same they
don't want you to believe in yourself
because to believe in your the only way
to truly believe in yourself the only
way to truly have self-confidence is to
earn it and to believe in what you're
able what is believe in yourself mean
think about that for a second let's say
let's say you've talked about this is a
funny if one of the funniest jokes a
burden where you said I was talking
about my grandfather in law who had
build built two houses yeah with his
bare hands
and you said I could we could probably
learn to do it you said I said I said
there's no way I would trust my saw I
wouldn't I wouldn't go in the second no
exactly so what is my chance now
yourself you can build the house believe
in yourself if you know you're not good
at it you don't believe in yourself you
believe in yourself in all this
when you achieve excellence and the left
doesn't want you to believe that the
left really because they want to remove
everything that makes us unique they
want you to be another faceless number
and here's one thing to people I've
changed a little bit this is why we've
spoken out against this most is why
we've been a little bit harsher with
Samantha be if there's one thing you
want to talk about believing in yourself
listen if you keep making the same
mistake over and over and you don't
judge yourself you need to be a little
judgmental of yourself if you don't make
those harsh judgments on yourself you're
never gonna correct it
you're gonna keep making a mistake and
you will not believe in yourself and
I've changed this a little bit where
I've had a lot of people email in and
say what should I do I'm in college my
professors are further left and I'm
afraid should I speak out and I said
well listen I I don't blame you if you
want to get your degree you'll want to
keep your grades up probably keep it
quiet you want to work in entertainment
sir you probably keep it quiet I will
tell you this you want to believe in
yourself you want to talk about mistakes
that you've made there is none greater
and this is why I've been changing to
every letter that I answer none greater
for destroying your own self-esteem than
cowardice that's actually one thing you
recommended Fargo that entire show the
theme is about confronting cowardice
there are a few things that I can say
specifically as a man I'm sure it's the
same as with women I'd like to hear from
you maybe if they're treating somebody
really well women are getting caddy and
you've you've stayed quiet I remember
one time I stayed quiet when they were
bullying a kid named Tony and I just
stayed quiet this was in grade school
because I was that this was the first
time I was not being the one bullied and
heard they were bullying him because he
said we were talking about the
Transformers we had to do a book report
and he was talking about this in front
of class and he said the Predacons
are sorry the Decepticons and the the
Autobots now at that time the show Beast
Wars or beasties if you were in the
States was big and so they were called
the Predacons these were the villains in
a new trend but the original
transformers he was right the
Decepticons and the whole class laughed
at him and they started making fun of
him and I knew what he meant I knew he
was right and no one said anything and I
didn't say anything and you know what I
felt bad about that for so long there
are very few times in my life where I
can say that I look back and I'm like
man I should have stood up I should have
stood up I should have said some in a
couple others some are personal maybe
I'll get into at some point maybe I
won't but I tell you what those are the
things that keep me up at night so if
you want self-esteem you want to believe
in yourself or your own rainbow
you want to actually have a true self
belief be good at something and I will
tell you what the mistake that will keep
you up at night is cowardice so I
changed that advice when you're in
college listen you know you know the
fight that's going on out there you know
if you want to be in the entertainment
history be vocal be bold it's the only
way this is going to change if you want
to change the K at the campus culture be
vocal be bold because there are a lot of
mistakes that you can make you can get a
number you can forget to carry the one
you can make mistakes and relationships
and maybe behaviorally and you can learn
to improve upon that but cowardice is
something that usually you've got a
split moment before you decide not to
same thing we've got a split moment
before you decided tuck tail and run
away and I will tell you it is a
terrible feeling and nothing and I mean
nothing out there will eat away at your
self-confidence at your self-esteem and
destroy your life like the repeated act
of cowardice so think of it all of us
have these areas in some part of our
life or were cowardly and we even try to
avoid or some maybe at some instance
that you know you acted wrong you know
you acted out of cowardice and you need
to fit do it do it because I guarantee
you do that right away it's gonna be a
weight lifted off your shoulders and all
of a sudden you're gonna have
self-esteem and you don't need equal
outcomes you just need to do the right
thing there is nothing more toxic to
your soul then repeatedly acting out of
cowardice believe me I've done it you'll
burn for it I know what I'm talking
about we're gonna see you next week
Monday a big change my mind speaking of
which I think that's pretty bold I might
get shot
[Music]